encuentra la ecuación de la recta que es
paralela a la recta 2 x 4 y igual a 8 y
pasa por el punto 3 0 dado que la recta
que nos piden es paralela a esta recta
es paralela a esta recta eso significa
que ambas tienen la misma pendiente
básicamente nos piden encontrar la
ecuación de la recta que tiene la misma
pendiente que esta recta y que pasa por
el punto 3,0 empecemos por calcular cuál
la pendiente de esta recta y la manera
más fácil es poner la ecuación en la
forma pendiente ordenada tenemos
entonces que la ecuación es 2x menos 4 y
igual a 8 lo que tenemos que hacer es
despejar y poner la ecuación en la forma
de igual a mx más sumemos entonces o
mejor dicho restemos 2x a ambos lados de
la ecuación así tenemos entonces que del
lado izquierdo esto se cancela nos queda
menos 4 y y del lado derecho menos 2 x
más 8 y estoy poniendo menos 2x primero
para tenerla en la forma mx más b ahora
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre menos 4 para qué
despejarla y entonces dividiendo todo
entre menos 4 del lado izquierdo nos
queda estos términos se cancelan nos
queda y de lado derecho nos queda menos
2 entre menos 4 es igual a un medio
entonces nos queda un medio de equis y 8
entre menos 4 es menos 2 así es que
tendríamos que sumar más menos 2 o
simplemente menos 2 así es que lo que
hemos hecho es tan solo reescribir la
ecuación de esta recta pero como ya la
tenemos en la forma m x mas b podemos
identificar que esta de aquí esta de
aquí es la pendiente esta de aquí es la
pendiente m así es que para la recta que
estamos buscando esta es la pendiente
por lo cual la ecuación de dicha recta
va a tener la forma de igual a un medio
de x más ordenada al origen no va a ser
exactamente esta ecuación no va a ser
esta misma ordenada al origen pero va a
tener la misma pendiente tienen distinta
ordenada al origen pero tienen la misma
pendiente son rectas paralelas así es
que ahora necesitamos calcular el valor
de b y para eso vamos a utilizar esta
información que tenemos aquí cuando x es
igual a 3 en esa recta cuando x es igual
a 3 y es igual a 0 así es que cuando x
es igual a 3 y es igual a 0 sustituyamos
en sus valores el ecuación 0 es igual a
un medio por 3 + b es decir en esta
recta el valor del orden al origen lo va
a calcular sustituyendo los valores del
punto por donde pasa el punto 30 así
tenemos 0 es igual a 3 medios más b
vamos a despejar de restamos tres medios
a ambos lados y que tenemos del lado
izquierdo nos queda menos tres medios
del lado derecho estos términos se
cancelan y nos queda b ya tenemos que el
valor de b es igual a menos tres medios
tenemos ya la ecuación de la recta
paralela a esta y que pasa por el punto
30 la ecuación de la recta que estamos
buscando es igual a un medio de x un
medio de x más mi b y la vez menos tres
medios menos tres medios y hemos
concluido de hecho si te interesa
podemos graficar estas dos rectas y
verificar que son paralelas voy a hacer
aquí unos ejes o hace un esbozo muy
rápido de las rectas entonces aquí
tenemos mi eje y mi eje x y vamos a
graficar las rectas tenemos la recta 2x
menos 4 igual a 8 la vamos a tomar de
esta manera de la forma mx más de él
sería checamos que el orden al origen es
menos 2 y vamos a graficar aquí tenemos
la orden al origen que es menos 2 y la
pendiente
un medio quiere decir que avanzamos 2
hacia la derecha y 1 hacia arriba 2
hacia la derecha y 1 hacia arriba
trazamos la línea aproximadamente donde
estaría esa pendiente de un medio y aquí
tenemos la recta la t recta la otra
recta tiene una ordenada el origen de
menos tres medios vamos a ubicar la
orden al origen de menos tres medios
siquiera menos dos menos tres medios
está pegadita pero ahí donde estaba la
otra y la pendiente es la misma
pendiente de un medio trazamos la recta
está muy pegada a una de otra pero son
rectas paralelas ya se ven estas rectas
son paralelas pero tienen diferente
ordenada el origen